hey there mark Sanderson here also known
as script cat I want to invite you to my
new seminar stayin in the game surviving
as a working screenwriter in Hollywood
sponsored by film courage it's going to
be two hours of me offering up my tips
tricks tactics and disciplines that can
actually help you establish your own
screenwriting career now we're gonna
have a QA to follow and also a chance to
get my new book that's September 25th
Tuesday night from 7 to 9 p.m. in North
Hollywood hope to see you there
what about advice to writers have been
fired off a project well you know
there's there's a firing and then
there's sort of like we're going to go
with someone else you know which is a
firing it's not quite as like you're
fired it's always thank you very much
and now we're going to have this other
writer finish it and then you share
credit you know what I would say to them
is learn from what happened on that with
that particular producer and not make
those mistakes again or maybe they're
not as good of a writer as they thought
they were so they were able to get in
with the script but they weren't able to
stay on it which i think is important to
stay through the end luckily on most of
my projects I've stayed through the end
and sometimes even been on the set doing
rewrites because the director wanted me
there I had that relationship with with
the key you know members but you want to
stay through the whole thing you don't
want to be the person that leaves if
you're leaving because you have another
job and you can't do it that's different
but if you're leaving because they don't
want you anymore
then that you probably won't work with
that producer again what if it's a
combination of that and politics and you
know that let's suppose there's a little
bird in your ear letting you know that
you know they brought someone else on
and that person's worked with that other
person before throw it and you know that
and you just have to kind of swallow
your pride in us well that happened to
me when I was working on the game show
you know I was told this is earlier one
of my first professional jobs I was told
that I didn't have enough
experience to do a certain during
production experience and I went through
the development of six weeks of writing
the show and then they shoot the show
but during that point I was let go and
they said we're bringing in somebody
with some ones who had a connection in
the writers room and I thought well I
went through the whole writing I don't
understand but it was just strange how
yeah you know and I was let go and I was
like okay I understand but it was it was
hard to be let go you know because I had
taken that job and I had quit my
restaurant career so-called as a waiter
and that was my first professional job
and then to lose it that's why in the
book I say how I was fired from my first
professional job at Christmas right at
Christmastime you know but it happens
and then you you're not guaranteed
anything you know the hardest thing that
I had to learn when I first started
getting paid to write was that I thought
everything I wrote would get made of
course it would be well I have probably
five projects sitting on a shelf there
production-ready I was paid for all the
drafts and nothing myriad of reasons
because the marketplace changes
economics their buyers decided to go
with a different genre the actor bowed
out and they want you know financing
felt through all things that were not my
problem you know I'm just the writer
right but that was the hardest thing but
I mean it's not hard anymore I realized
the realities of the business did not
you know and but that was the hardest
thing I thought everything I wrote would
be made I never thought that when I
wrote my specs of course obviously to
every spec your rights gonna sell right
but to be let go of a job you you have
to learn and why it's a learning
experience you don't want too many you
know what you know that to happen too
many times because then the word will
get around and you won't work but no no
your producers and what they want you
know and so luckily the producers I work
with I know kind of now after working it
for so long what they want and that's
what they want they won't have to leave
you alone
maybe where is he gonna turn in the
thing and you know cuz we got people
waiting and a lot of money you know they
don't want to have to worry
about that but you have to build into
that you know so a writer that gets in
somehow luck maybe whatever sells the
script but doesn't have that ability to
see it through to the end that's a
terrible thing because you think oh I've
sold it now yeah and you're not staying
on it because you can't do the rewrites
you know I'm sorry but we need to take
this into production and we need to get
through development and if you can't do
it we will find someone who can how was
Christmas that year uh it was okay not
great because I was without a job you
know well not only that sorry to
interrupt but you know you were leaving
one world oh yeah to go to this world
that you've been waiting for
yes and it's Christmas I got through
Christmas and how was New Year's it was
fine because a few months later my spec
was optioned oh okay so I was you know I
rose from the ashes like a phoenix you
know so I was like didn't have to go
back to the restaurant and vowed and I
never did so that that you know that's
my point about having multiple projects
or things if I had nothing else that I
would be out knocking on doors gonna huh
you know but that if you charted the
course before that first job that spec
was was constantly trying to find its
way and finally ended up with with the
proper timing the right home with the
company said we want to make this
you